it's the beginning of a new coalition to
end the war on drugs as we know it the
presidents of Mexican Colombia the two
countries most affected by Cartel
violence or spearheading an effort to
change the global fight against
narcotics
solving the scourge of drug addiction
and violence lies in addressing its
causes with the new criteria not only
thinking about coercive measures we have
to think first that peace is the fruit
of Justice we have to fight against
poverty and inequality first
the two presidents LED an International
Conference in the Colombian city of Cali
in which 19 countries agreed on a
10-point document that War on Drugs is a
failure and requires a revision
Colombian president Gustavo Petro said
it's time to focus on reducing demand in
developed countries
capitalism and it's later face has a lot
societies that today consume drugs to
loneliness that's the reason they
consume drugs the drugs replace the lack
of affection and loneliness but I am not
supposed to say that because the
official drug policy is not to cut the
demand it is to cut the supply End by
force
a trillion dollars spent to fight drugs
over the last few decades and a half a
million deaths in Latin America the
production of cocaine remains at an
all-time high and drug trafficking keeps
expanding to countries that until
recently had been spared like Ecuador
but while they agree on the causes Latin
American countries remain divided when
it comes to reaching a consensus on a
new model to legalize or regulate drugs
like cocaine in the past I think there
was thought that there was a simple
solution and that by stronger police
forces or otherwise and especially in
this region that that would be enough to
remove the entire problem of drug
addiction in the world and obviously
we've seen that is not the case and
Narco traffickers have also adapted and
continued to do so Colombia and Mexico
hope this conference in Cali will be the
first step towards a more comprehensive
response to this worldwide problem they
are promising to bring a united front to
the next U.N Commission on narcotics in
2024 and are calling for a global Summit
of world presidents in 2025. Alessandro
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera